it certainly creates a much stronger
conditioning when the reward is very
variable unpredictable you want you want
you want a variable reward here it is
right here okay
because when that email goes off you
know if it's good or bad the lottery
it's the lottery it's the slot machine
I've got a slot machine in your pocket I
think there are actually multiple
processes involved in what leads to
these unhealthy relationships with
smartphones so there's social anxiety
there's you know our desire for approval
there's avoidance so when we don't want
to really confront uncomfortable things
that we can use our phones as an escape
all these kind of things were always
with us but this technology is
amplifying all of them most people
especially around here have jobs that
require them to use computers and
computers have now become this force
that is kind of inserted itself into our
lives and we can't extricate ourselves
from it voluntarily there's this
interesting rising tide of hey maybe we
should be teaching ethics maybe we
should be teaching emotional
intelligence and diversity inclusion
equity and you know authentic relating
divergent thinking in addition you're
typing while you're talking to the
patient instead of talking to the
patient there's no eye contact the
entire humanity of the medical discourse
is gone when your child's born with an
iPad rather than your child's born we're
looking at the eyes of other humans
clinical depression is up eighteen point
five percent worldwide Wow four point
four percent of all people on the planet
now carry a diagnosis of clinical
depression
[Music]
what's up all you beautiful people how
you doing yeah whoa some good energy I
love it I love it
are you guys excited to talk about
ethical tech yeah yeah yeah we're
excited we're really excited psychology
neuroscience behavioral ethics and
behavioral economics attention economics
social media 2.0 mental health and
well-being
Melissa's never ending all these complex
disciplines that merge together into
what we will be talking about today who
here has been to a simulation event
before live reload applause a little
applause today let's hear it okay so we
got a bunch of some some people have
some people are newbies cool stuff night
my name is Alan sake and I host
simulation we're rebirthing the public
intellectual or multidisciplinary daily
show and live event series we're hoping
to scale our live events up at the
sports stadiums Rhys Jones told me that
that was a not ambitious enough of a
dream he's he's been he's been helping
me figure figure things out how to do
how to do it much love to you guys for
coming out tonight this is in
partnership with work-wise this is in
partnership with civility before
bringing max up the founder civility to
talk to you guys about civility which is
freaking awesome
I want to thank work wise as you can
tell the space is very green it's very
open it invites very creative people
here to collaborate in and they have a
very strong back-end system that links
people together that are building
important futures so definitely go check
out work wise the founders are not here
tonight which is why they're not
speaking about it but check them out
work wise calm huge thank you for
hosting us max Marty go ahead and join
us talk about civility man we're
elevating conversation I'm really
excited to be hosting this with you
indeed indeed thank you everybody for
coming out out of curiosity who here has
been to a civility discussion not pause
applause yeah do we beat you there Ellen
I don't know alright so for those of you
who don't know civility is a service
that allows intellectually curious
people
like yourselves to be able to coordinate
in-person face-to-face discussions on
topics of interest to them and this
tonight is sort of like a civility
discussion although with two important
two very big and important differences
firstly civilities discussions usually
don't involve lights and an audience and
cameras and how this other stuff right
it's like an in-person discussion six
people just like here but without all of
this additional excitement and the other
thing is that civility discussions are
for intellectually curious people who
are who are excited about a topic but
are not necessarily subject matter
experts right like we like we have on
the stage tonight so with those two
important differences please enjoy this
simulation of a civility discussion I
think it was a good one come on come on
Oh Lu spend all night on that one all
right
I want to make sure everybody who's
who's here in the middle is building
really important futures for the next
evolution of how we engage with each
other and through technology and there's
there's a we have a very diverse array
of people here first we have Wilmot a
here he is the head of the San Francisco
Bay Area Humane tech chapter give it up
for will robert lustig yeah pediatric
endocrinologist and emeritus professor
pediatrics at UCSF he's also the author
of the hacking of the American mind the
science of the corporate takeover of our
bodies and brains let's give Robert a
round of applause
Joseph vo gosh is a clinical
psychologist and postdoc at Stanford
researching neuroscience of well-being
and mental health let's give it up for
Joseph and lastly Andrew Marie Dunn
founder of CFO whoo all right so let's
jump into conversation there's so many
things to talk about I wanna maybe I
want to I want to start off by asking
you for in max as well what's been your
synthesis of everything that's been
going on let's start with the synthesis
and then we can break down into separate
categories and things like that yeah who
wants to start us off it's a tough it's
a tough one to jump into a synthesis of
it all indeed since I'm holding the mic
I will begin
I think the synthesis of what we're
seeing now is hopefully in my opinion a
nascent societal shift in the way we
view and interact with technology up
until very recently the overwhelming
kind of cultural narrative that we've
been living in is one where technology
and in particular high technology the
internet computers have been really seen
in as very positive force in a world
where people think that they can people
creating technology can kind of do no
wrong and things like Facebook and
Google and video games are very positive
things that will shape our lives for the
better and just really in the last
couple years people have started to kind
of come to realize that there are
actually all these negative
externalities and effects of technology
that they maybe didn't fully comprehend
previously and we are starting to see
much more discussion and reflection on
the role of Technology in our lives and
really taking a more holistic approach
to understanding what it does to us so
I'm really curious to hear what
everybody else has to say about the
synthesis of the current state of
Technology but that's my personal
bottom where we are at the moment so you
to have that mic so I'm gonna be a
little bit more dire and gloom and doom
if it fits my persona what I see I've
been a pediatric endocrinologist for 40
years what I see is a pandemic
not an epidemic a pandemic of addiction
and depression now you could say well
you know that's opioids and that's you
know other things but technology plays a
huge role in that it's not the only
thing in fact there are five things that
have happened to our society over the
last 50 years technology processed food
sugar lack of sleep drugs and every
single one of those affects the brain in
exactly the same way and when it affects
the brain in exactly this same way you
end up with a neuroscientific meltdown
excessive dopamine driving addiction and
not enough serotonin driving depression
and addiction depression are just two
sides of the same coin
now I'm not pinning it all on technology
but you have to explain why there's been
a tripling in the suicide rate over the
last ten years since the introduction of
the iPhone we had processed food before
that we had lack of sleep before that we
had drugs before that something changed
ten years ago yes that's a powerful
statement
so my field is in the neuroscience of
emotion and mental health and well-being
and and I really said some of the things
that I've been thinking about which are
that we have kind of a new something new
in our society to grapple with just the
same way as we've had to grapple with
new chemicals new foods new changes to
our environment and the
and part of what's happening is we are
figuring out our relationship with it
and with our brains which evolutionarily
are much older and are designed to
handle much a much different set of
influences so one of the things that we
are in the process of doing and the I
see happening around me now and maybe
I'll I'll strike a little bit more of an
optimistic tone just you know for for
balancing is that we're evolving we're
evolving systems we're evolving norms in
socially and we're also evolving
personal practices and elements of our
lifestyle that will allow us to maintain
mental health and well-being which is
really my central concern in an
environment where we have this new and
confusing and bewildering and
unpredictable technology available to us
as a start-up founder I'm running up
against the friction of existing
economic models with the intentions of
alignment with the best interests of
people and the planet and yeah it's this
it's this challenge of living in
integrity with what we know needs to
happen and minimizing the unintended
consequences the unknown unknowns with
trying to create a real business that
sustains itself and grows and so this
challenge of how do we feel
private-sector innovation in a system
that rewards the the fast exit the grow
at all costs whether it's you know
negative externalities or the mental
health of employees and yeah that's
that's what I'm seeing I think I would
add that there's been a confluence of
factors outside of merely
the hard work of a number of companies
like Facebook and Twitter and such who
actually addictive but like Robert was
saying it's it's a number of factors
that are potentially coming together and
breaking the camel's back in this
situation however optimistically I would
also add that that innovators have
always
we get into these these these new
paradigms that that look scary and
dangerous with the advent of new
technologies especially new information
technologies but I think that we will
develop a cultural immune system through
the new sets of norms and such as we've
been describing and hopefully innovators
especially given where we are here in
the Bay Area
who are finally waking up to the many
problems that are being caused by by
these companies are going to be stepping
up and offering us offering all of us
better alternatives that that speak more
to the humanity in us and to the to the
life that we actually want to live nice
good synthesises
there's there's there's something about
when I when I when I look at the
evolution of the internet age which is
where I kind of want to take us next
Robert started us a little bit in the
realm of what to attribute the increase
in suicide threefold suicide increases
that in the United States are in the
world do you know someone take the mic
when you speak so we can get on yeah
that those data for the United States
but clinical depression is up eighteen
point five percent worldwide Wow four
point four percent of all people on the
planet now carry a diagnosis of clinical
depression so so this is you know and
this is an extremely nuanced topic we
like to get into the multi variability
and not just you know binary thinking on
on topics and and this especially is a
really tough one because it's really
quite incredible that you can do a video
chat with someone on the other half of
the planet but it's also kind of crazy
that that they can ping you anytime and
disrupt your workflow so these are this
is thing this is the nuance that we hope
to unpack in the civil discourse I want
to I want to see what do you guys think
about now the the evolution of
Technology and the Internet age and how
that's affected humanity we're starting
we're starting to unpack that so I want
to know what you think you use used to
be that you had to write a letter and
then you had to wait for it to get
to someone does anyone remember that
who's old enough to remember that yeah
there we go
yeah no I don't know I don't know I do
it so buddy I got called out he's like
you don't remember that yeah Punk yeah
that's funny so so so we yeah so now
it's an instant it's an instant message
you don't have to wait so now how many
more messages are we sending because
they're instant instead of having to
wait so long etc so tell us about what
do you what are your thoughts are on the
evolution of Technology and the internet
and how that's affected humanity one
thing I think is really fascinating
about the current paradigm that we're
living in with technology is this
phenomenon of technology having a lot of
utility for people so it's really useful
I mean nobody's denying that the
Internet's been super helpful in a lot
of regards however the very tools that
we use to make our lives better are
often wrapped up in other things that
actually make our lives worse so for
example if you're trying to connect with
your friends who don't live in the same
place that you do now there's this
wonderful thing that we can use to do
that but that tool is actually designed
to be addictive so you wind up addicted
to a service that you really can't not
use in many instances I mean you can go
completely off the grid and live in the
woods and remove yourself from society
once a year it's off stage here yeah so
you can live in a yurt but you can't
participate in society without also
indulging yourself in these technologies
that can totally loop you in
I mean I think that's a really shocking
you know situation to be in for example
nobody has a job smoking cigarettes or
watching television or I mean very very
few people maybe you can say that you
know there's like the Marlboro
advertisers to you know get paid to
model of cigarettes but in general
people do not have jobs using addictive
substances or gambling or you know any
other kind of canonical example of
addiction however everyone or you know
not everyone most people especially
around here have jobs that require them
to use computers
and computers have now become this
forced it's kind of inserted itself into
our lives and we can't extricate
ourselves from it voluntarily I should
mention that I retired a year ago
because of computers is the electronic
medical record was either quit or died
we decided to quit what wait so tell us
the introduction of the electric
electronic medical record yeah that
killed me yeah why why have you ever
used it yeah what about it it's it's
it's unction you sit down at the
keyboard and you can't make a screen go
away it's there forever in addition
you're typing while you're talking to
the patient instead of talking to the
patient there's no eye contact
the entire humanity of the medical
discourse is gone you your physician is
now just described is is there a and
when you when that happens there's
really no point in being a doctor well
what about looking at them and talking
to them about how they feel and then
when you come up with an analysis for
the electronic health record you can
turn around type it in and then or sure
and it'll be home three hours later yep
yeah I mean it took took takes three
hours to do the charting so we moved to
Mission Bay
you know from Parnassus so as an hour
commute they're an hour commute back and
three more hours of extra charting yeah
sure yeah but wife was real happy about
that but then there is also a the
benefit of being able to have a medical
record that's that's that when you get
an entry at at a hospital different
hospitals that you can they have a
record of you you know what if you are
cutting and pasting everyone else's
notes into yours you don't have a
medical record you have a running data
stream and you have to spend more time
trying to fish out what's important then
if you actually read somebody's note so
it doesn't work if anybody reads the New
Yorker I told go one they just had it
nice piece in The New Yorker just a week
ago why doctors hate computers exhibit
Wow the human connection that was a big
point there yeah right and as a clinical
psychologist I actually I also
experienced this in our whole job is
really to create connection and empathy
with our patients and I've been in
settings where we're actually expected
to chart on the computer as we're
talking to somebody about their
emotional issues and it's a real
challenge so I think this is definitely
one of these areas where I hope I mean
this is actually an area where maybe
there's also a technological solution
and we can get the screens out of the
way and still be capturing useful
information wasted text and then have
that input into the fields potentially
yeah that kind of thing but to talk
about the evolution of Technology of
Internet technology I think it may be
this fits in is the the thing that came
to my mind is that it's an amplifier so
when in mental health particularly there
were all kinds of processes that we've
that have been with us ferns to take
bullying in high schools and social
judgment and kind of questing for social
approval all those things have been
around for a long time but now when you
have text messaging all of a sudden an
entire school can actually you know
bully a kid 24/7 with nobody around to
even hear what they're saying and at the
same time on the flip side you have
Instagram and snapchat where now you can
be kind of basically constantly not just
kind of going to school and trying to
wear something that like the cool kids
will like but actually basically doing
your own fashion photo shoots all day
every day and then you know constantly
getting feedback and approval ratings
and watching your ratings go up and down
so it's the same the same process
disapproval ratings yeah absolutely
right and so we you know there's the
reward side of things and then I also
think I think there are actually
multiple processes involved in what
leads to these unhealthy relationships
with smartphones so there's social
anxiety there's you know our desire for
approval
there's avoidance so when we don't want
to really confront uncomfortable things
that we can use our phones as an escape
all these kind of things were always
with us but this technology is
amplifying all of them
I'm tracking the evolution of
consciousness of the people who are
creating these tools technology is an
extension of choice making power and
throughout history consumer tech has
become regulated when it is proven to be
dangerous or have harmful impacts but
we're seeing technology evolve so
rapidly and there's this race to figure
out the business model and you know for
the rocket fuel on it so we're now
bumping up against the limits of that
and there's this interesting rising tide
of hey maybe we should be teaching
ethics maybe we should be teaching
emotional intelligence and diversity
inclusion equity and you know authentic
relating divergent thinking all these
ways of asking like was the thing we're
trying to do and how can we do it in a
way that respects the human animal and
allows for flourishing and so it's
really cool to see that start to be
adopted more I'm starting to see more
friends who are engineers and some these
big companies and also found there's
also investors who are really going deep
and trying to understand their fears and
their biases because everything we
create is an expression of who we are
and what we value so that's going to go
into your team that's gonna go into your
product and we don't have a lot of
answers because there's not a lot of
great examples and stories to look to of
people who've done that well I'm excited
to keep tracking it yeah when you say
when you say that we should be teaching
those sorts of values do you mean we the
builders of these products do you mean
we parents of children who are suffering
in this situation do you mean we
regulators do you mean we people who are
concerned about this in the culture at
large who want to speak about who are
the we I think we all have to explore
these questions and I don't think a
singular body of people or entities can
make these decisions for such a complex
societal topic yeah except for one
little problem we have this thing called
children so I'm an old guy I'm also a
pediatrician so I've gotten to watch a
different evolution I've gotten to watch
the evolution of children in my clinic
the last 40 years thousands of kids do
you think you've seen all together yeah
40 years yeah 20,000 20,000 maybe you
know few so you know like one of the
typical icebreakers that we used to say
or yeah ask a kid what do you want to be
when you grow up 40 years ago dr. your
rocket scientist baseball player good
humor man you know something last 15
years
oh you ask a kid well you want to be
when you grow up I don't know not a clue
not a clue so what happened I'll tell
you what happened this happened because
when the 15 month old comes in and knows
how to use the iPad better than me
they're doing it that's the portable
babysitter
that is the distractor that's why the
iPads there is to distract the kid it
doesn't have to learn to self-soothe the
kid doesn't have a chance to have a
thought of their own no imagination no
imagination
no wonder they don't know what they want
to be when they grow up no imagination
Piaget famous child psychologist of the
you know ancient times once said that
play is the work of the child
well boredom is the opportunity of the
child and our children are never bored
and it's playing out now so the there's
also an incredibly I guess amazing
aspect of what child being able to just
parse the internet for whatever
knowledge they want to obtain so there's
this incredible amount of you you look
at a community that wasn't able to talk
to each other because they didn't have
the internet infrastructure then they
gain Internet infrastructure and then
they're able to communicate
Kait with each other and then that does
so many beneficial things for that
community to flourish on the planet and
then there's a child that has this
potentially yes this this there's this
detriment of being so immersed in an
iPad that they're not able to maybe find
some sort of other meaning or
fulfillment in their in their childhood
so you know they're there this is
extremely nuanced now I want to know but
kind of between those two sides you do
tell us about some of the nuance that
you found to be interesting on you know
on the positive on the negative for
children for middle for adults where it
wherever you think is important to
discuss well I want to start by saying
that I think I am part of the absolute
oldest cohort of people who grew up with
the internet and modern computers truly
from the beginning I started using the
Internet when I was 2 years old
in 1995 I'm 24 now and interestingly in
my life
the Internet has played a huge role it's
done a lot of positive things I learned
a lot on the Internet I was extremely
addicted to reading about interesting
topics that I was learning about both in
school and outside of school so I had an
indelibly positive impact on my life
however over the past few years I
started to recognize that what it's once
started as a healthy habit and behavior
had migrated didn't become an unhealthy
addiction and interestingly enough one
thing I wanted to ask the panel about
was this this whole premise of our talk
is about the attention economy and I'm
really curious about how that fits in
with this whole paradigm of addiction
and mental health issues that were
currently experiencing so one thing that
I thought was really fascinating about
my own experience with internet
addiction with a lot of people I
actually spoke with was people were
addicted to things like you know
Facebook and Twitter I mean I think I
think everyone come here probably
recognizes that those things can be
addictive however a lot of people who I
know are also addicted to Wikipedia
which is this repository of knowledge
it's a non-profit and well that's the
thing so I was completely addicted to
Wikipedia read literally thousands of
articles spent literally thousands of
hours doing it
started using it in 2004 like a year
after it was founded so very very early
learned probably just as much there as I
did in school to be honest uh and
however over the last year I realized
that I was spending hours and hours on
Wikipedia and not actually really
learning anything and I actually
realized that I was no longer coming to
Wikipedia for the information I was
coming there because I felt compelled to
scroll through each page and I was
actually rereading articles that I'd
already read ten times before just
purely out of a compulsion so it was
really no longer serving any sort of
purpose it was really just a habit and
behavior in and of itself that was
perpetuating itself so I think that
these sort of things can begin healthy
and positive and eventually transition
and become negative and actually
detrimental to your life so how much of
do you think that this stuff so with
Wikipedia in particular I think it's
really interesting that it's nonprofit
how much of these problems do you think
are actually caused by the profit motive
of these companies making a lot of
technology and how much of it do you
think is caused by other factors or
maybe just the way humans inherently use
technology I want it I dress your
question but but first I think there's
bring an elephant is an elephant in the
room that we have to clear first we've
been throwing this term around up here
addiction internet addiction who here
believes in Internet addiction why how
can it be addictive it's not a drug
all right so you have to understand the
definition of addiction so once upon a
time the DSM the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual which comes out every
20 years in 1993 the DSM for defined
addiction as two phenomena tolerance and
withdrawal now it turns out tolerance is
the down regulation of dopamine
receptors in an area of the brain called
the reward center or the nucleus
accumbens when those neurons start to
die that's called addiction and dopamine
is an excitatory neurotransmitter kills
neurons chronic excess dopamine leads to
neuronal cell death Robert seems to make
a little sorry chronic excess dopamine
leads to neuronal cell death now for
cocaine for heroin for nicotine for
alcohol even for sugar which is you know
I got my start in this whole business
you know people are very you know
understanding of this concept of
addiction but it's because of the
withdrawal withdrawal you needed the
tolerance and withdrawal so withdrawal
turns out our systemic effects of all of
these drugs so opioids have effects on
the GI tract and your lacrimal glands
cocaine has effects on your adrenergic
system and set etc caffeine you know the
the jitters the the DTS for alcohol okay
so everyone could see or experience the
systemic effects of withdrawal of any
given substance so there's easy to call
substances addictive but what about
behaviors there's no substance
there's no withdrawal but we know
they're addictive and because the same
phenomena is going on in the brain and
it's the causing the same cell death
it's just doesn't have the systemic
effects because there's no drug so in
2013 the dsm-5 redefined addiction as
tolerance and dependence well will you
just described tolerance independence
so in fact it is addiction under the new
rubric under the new definition you have
to understand that because there are a
lot of you techies out there okay who
are very willing to buy into this notion
that this is just habit not addiction it
is and when you understand that you
understand why and you understand the
neuroscience behind it then you can get
on board and you can't get on board
until you understand that so the topic
of behavioral addiction is a really hot
one and really debated actually and I I
think I appreciate what you're saying
and for the sake of nuance I also I
think there are a couple of things that
are worth pointing out one being what
difference is it's easy to equate you
know something like cocaine to Internet
addiction and like we you know when when
you followed neuroscience press coverage
you're constantly seeing these studies
you know that cheese activates the same
neurons in your brain as cocaine so you
know cheese addiction is just like you
know doing a lime and and and there I
mean yes it's you know it's true and the
reason it's true is because all of these
circuits in our brain are reused and
used over and over again for all kinds
of processes in our life right so I you
know that you mentioned like that you
know none of us have a job drinking
alcohol right but we all eat right and
and so we all actually do have to go
through you know life engaging at least
three times a day you know with these
substances that you know trigger these
reward systems in our brain one
important thing that's different about
chemical addiction versus something like
the Internet is that the chemicals like
cocaine are actually driving your brain
outside of its biological parameters so
they're flooding your receptors they're
causing the release of neurotransmitters
to a level that actually is not
biologically normal and part of that's
actually part of why you have these
pathological effects I am feta mean
actually reverses the transporters and
some in the membranes of the cells so
the
stead of up taking up neurotransmitters
that releasing them and so that leads to
down regulation of receptors it can also
lead to cell death but there's actually
I would say it's worth remembering that
that's not the same process that's
happening when you have a behavioral
reward which is actually what our brains
are designed to do so in a sense this is
taking a natural process and it's just
kind of like it's kind of like you know
when a bright light or sudden loud noise
happens you can't help but look at it
but you know think of that happening a
thousand times right so so I think it's
important to think of it that way I
don't actually believe in a sharp line
between habit and addiction I think
these things there's a spectrum so if
you if you look at say Charles doings
book the power of habit
he describes the circuit so there's the
trigger which you know like the itch and
there's the action which is like the
scratch and you know then you get a
reward for it even if it's sometimes
negative there's still a reward like
head picking okay I mean that would seem
extraordinarily negative but what it's
doing is it's ameliorating and
inhibiting chronic anxiety and stress
so you're still receiving a reward but
it's the same time every time you do it
that's called a habit the difference
between habit and addiction is that the
reward is variable and that's in near I
Al's book hooked how to formulate habit
it certainly creates a much stronger
conditioning when the rewards variable
unpredictable you want you want you want
a variable reward here it is right here
okay because when that email goes off
you don't know if it's good or bad the
lottery it's the lottery it's the slot
machine I've got a slot machine in your
pocket and any of you have ever gone to
Las Vegas or Tunica and watched people
mindlessly pour quarters into a slot
machine you know what's going on in
their brains just by looking at them
well guess what going on in yours too
you can almost vary the varied reward
increases the likelihood of addiction
yeah
and varied and unpredictable yeah so
you'll find that the rats will press you
know if they know that every time they
hit the lever they'll get a pellet
they'll actually kill folk kind of
confidence or security right so anytime
I want to tell it I'll just hit the
lever right but if they don't know how
many presses it's gonna take then
they'll sit there frantically pressing
it because they don't they don't know
you know maybe maybe it'll be this time
but who knows how long it's going to be
so I better get on that that's kind of
the the mechanism underlying that yeah
Wow yeah neuroscience of addiction
anybody familiar with dopamine labs
mm-hmm okay it's an LA company okay
designed to take your app and make it
addictive by introducing variable reward
that's how you take any app but what if
you're learning what if it's what if
it's learning I know that you know there
are certain ways to learn that are
obsessive like you are saying but then
there's also ways to learn as though you
can make a learning app addictive and it
can make a multi-disciplinary kid out of
technology it's possible some yeah yeah
excuse me so yeah just hitting some of
the positive tennis balls back every
once in a while yeah yeah that's when
the tricky things we put something out
there and any actor can use it for
whatever intentions they have what was
coming up for me during this last back
and forth was the Marshall McLuhan quote
we were talking about before 60 70 years
ago once we have surrendered our nervous
systems to the private manipulation of
those who seek to profit off our senses
we really don't have many rights left
and I think negative nuance that is
seldom named is the effect on our
nervous system our breath I think it's
probably the biggest yeah you wake up
you're on these things and it's just a
constant state of shortened breath
spiked heart rate and that leads to
chronic illness and I honestly as a
developer who's trying to reimagine how
can smartphones support our mental
health and well-being I want to throw a
hackathon where we just figure out all
the ways your phone could get you to
breathe more and better that's one of
the most important things that we've
lost maybe something we never really
knew how to do but is really in jeopardy
right now
it's causing lots of problems I'm very
curious how much of that jeopardy is
being caused by the profit motive of
these companies creating this technology
I mean I think one thing that's gotten a
lot of flack recently is the ad based
revenue model where companies try to
make you use their product as much as
possible for as long as possible because
they can show you more advertisements
however but if it's a meditation app
then what's wrong with that but also
with in addition to that there seems to
be some things that are not designed
with that motive and yet they're still
really addictive to certain people so
it's a question of what's really causing
this addiction what's causing this
mental behavior it's clearly that's also
contributing to it the profit motive of
these companies but there might be
something more than that there's a great
point about the nervous system I totally
see that and feel it it's it's a sense
of tension in so many ways and not a
sense of heart coherence and residents
we're not running around we're running
around in our heads more I think because
of Technology in some ways when your
child's born with an iPad rather than
your child's born we're looking at the
eyes of other humans more often I think
there's less heart intention there Lou
max can I can I go to the can move on
you can want to say something can I move
on so this is this is bringing up for me
a memory that I have of of my own
situation but one thing that I would
maybe this is slightly moving on so okay
the right time to say this cool to bring
this up but gaming right so computer
gaming I think is one of the early
places where we saw a lot of companies
refining the ways in which they're
developing addictive technologies this
variable reward system was used in
gaming for a long time or you know you'd
you'd kill the monster and then
occasionally it would drop something
that you'd want it wouldn't you know
it's exactly it was it was definitely
refined there very well you went for the
slot machine right into the gaming world
however I I also want to I don't know if
this is an optimistic tone or a deeply
cynical one maybe I'm not sure you guys
can tell me but there are many people
for whom so so I used to play World of
Warcraft
when I was younger okay so you know full
reveal here we're on the couches this is
the right place to talk about it right
but but in college I think I spent as
much time playing World of Warcraft as I
did actually doing you know legitimate
work in school I spend more time playing
video games there you go who knows where
I would be right but but I rose in the
in the in the World of Warcraft world
you know I became a guild leader and I
had all these you know I have a ran a
hundred people and my guild and we did
this great stuff and blah blah blah but
I remember a lot of the people who were
playing that game who I knew and who I
got to know through there it's not like
they had these amazing lives and if only
they hadn't been playing World of
Warcraft they would have been curing
cancer or you know up on this stage or
something they they often had what I
would categorize as very mundane boring
jobs you know they they they they
weren't enjoying their daily they would
they would go through their job
basically just well enough to be able to
pay the the Internet bill and to pay the
World of Warcraft monthly subscription
fee get home and now they'd be slaying
dragons you know they'd be they'd be
consorting with all of the interesting
people in the in the community and doing
all these things that there was an
addictive component to it but there was
also a sense in which it gave them
meaning identity and purpose and perhaps
meaning identity and purpose that they
wouldn't otherwise have had in their
lives I know it gave me a sense of
meaning identity and purpose in a time
of my life when I felt like I was just
you know just some college student just
some number and and I found it enjoyable
so maybe I was partly addicted or you
know whatever it and then and then but I
was also deriving some of these benefits
so was I wrong to be deriving these
benefits you know should I should I
should I still be locked in a basement
somewhere playing World of Warcraft all
day except rather than being up here and
what is the effect of technologies like
indistinguishable virtual realities what
is the effect of of technology that that
that puts us in a world that we prefer
to be in virtually rather than in the
real world once it once it gets so good
so what do we do with the essence of
finding meaning in virtual worlds rather
than finding meaning in our real world
and and who are we to say that you know
who those of us who are you know most of
the people in this room I'm sure many of
us are quite successful you know are up
on this stage we're in the Bay Area etc
etc who are we to say that their lives
are you know that the fact that that
they're that they're sitting on Facebook
all day or that they're playing World of
Warcraft all day well that's a
meaningless existence that's that's not
what the kind of world that we want to
live now I'm sure I'm sure you know all
right I'm teeing it up for you here
Robert I'll let you go ahead yeah I
don't I I I'm not gonna tell you that
it's a meaningless or meaningful
existence that's not the issue the issue
is is it addicting you or is it
depressing you because it's doing one or
the other or both they can't be doing
neither Zuckerberg says he's you know
you can quote me because I'm quoting him
depressed people use Facebook because
they're looking for social validation
that they can't get anywhere else and
whether you use do it with World of
Warcraft or you know anything or any
other you know device or method you know
we used to have Trekkies when I was a
kid you know that was that was the early
version I'm one of those yeah well you
know he says depressed people use
Facebook because they're looking for
social validation except for one thing
when you look at the time lag analysis
data doesn't matter if you're depressed
when you start or when you whether
you're you know not depressed when you
start if you perfectly have everyone
gets more depressed using Facebook we
have the data that actually shows when
you do the time lag analysis everyone
becomes more depressed and the reason is
because Facebook ups your dopamine well
guess what as it opens you don't mean it
downs your serotonin because everything
that ups you don't mean downs you
as a poll of the audience does anybody
feel as though their happiness just like
continues and continues to increase as
they use a social platform just does
that does it feel yeah yeah yeah you
yeah tell us I'm gonna go out on a limb
here in in college Facebook was my world
of warcraft I had really unhealthy
dependency on it and it distract him
from studies and probably all sorts of
other things and then through this
digital wellness journey largely
self-directed and now also empowered by
new tools and communication contracts
and things I I think I have a much
healthier relationship with the products
which is an extremely powerful tool for
organizing and connecting with people
yes
putting your intentions and asked out
there and inviting in the support it's
insane and I've noticed a lot more over
the last year that it seems like a lot
of people who seem to move effortlessly
through the world are really skilled at
using Facebook yeah in a grounded
balanced way we're not necessarily
teaching people how to do that Facebook
is not necessarily training you had to
do it and it requires some hacks and
workarounds but nobody's telling you
teaching you how to not reply to a
message so that you can continue
focusing on your project that you're
working on yeah there's there's that
component of it too it's these things
are complicated yeah I want we'll we'll
have Q&A yes yes correct just on this
note there's an increasing amount of
evolutionary ties to what's going on as
we've been talking about there's a
evolutionary hypothesis called the
show-off hypothesis that you would come
back to your village with either a lot
of berries or a lot of meat or whatever
it may be new items new tools and your
Vil your fellow villagers would be very
excited and they'd be very happy for for
the village and then you would get up
ranked in the social clout of the
village and similarly you post onto the
social platforms to get up ranked by
your village of humans it's in order for
you to your clout to rise and then
there's other aspects to this which is
now the voices
very strange in terms of having lots of
having lots of noise and having less
signal I can't tell if there is a lower
signal-to-noise ratio now than there was
50 years ago before all the the computer
and Internet age I'm curious if you
think the signal-to-noise ratio has
decreased if so why and and furthermore
what are the social network 2.0 is like
see what cm Poe is doing in many ways
like what the ethical tech research
that's being done like civility is doing
as well what what where does the city
how does signal-to-noise where do you
think about what do you think about that
and then also what do you think about
the social network 2.0 is mindfulness
and emotional health as well along the
way so I personally think that when it
comes to social networks 2.0 I think a
lot of people hear this and they think
oh it's going to be like Facebook but
with ethics so it'll be an ethical
version of Facebook and in my opinion I
do not believe that a social network 2.0
is going to look anything like what we
currently conceive of as a social
network because I think that the reasons
why people say that you social networks
are actually different than the reasons
that you actually use social networks
and I think a lot of people who think oh
I'm gonna create Facebook 2.0 but you
know I'm not gonna steal people's
privacy private data
I'm not going to addicting to Facebook
they think that people are going to
Facebook to connect with their friends
and share important information in their
lives when they're actually going to
Facebook to procrastinate and look at
pictures of people they find really
attractive and you know feel very
outraged to stimulate their adrenaline
by reading posts but make them feel
really upset and angry I think people
who go into the social network 2.0
paradigm often think oh I'm going to
help people connect with their friends
ethically but they don't realize that
maybe there are actual reasons people
use Facebook are different than what we
often think they are what do you think
about the signal-to-noise being lower
now than it was 50 years ago
what do you think about that well where
do you stand on it
so signal tonight just to make sure I'm
understanding correctly so signal is
like the importance of content or actual
relevance of it and the noise is just
the things that are okay so I think the
signal noise ratio is definitely
decreased a lot or namely there's a lot
more noise than than signal than there
used to be and that's because media self
is proliferated into a thousand
different modes of communication whereas
in the past it was very very
consolidated with just a couple kind of
monopolistic forms of communication in
addition to that media now is really in
the hands of everyone everyone can
create a Facebook post whereas in the
past only a few people could create a TV
channel and broadcast a message that way
and if you look at the amount of
information that the average person is
exposed to it's drastically increased
over the last 50 years
oh really for actually hundreds of years
but but in the last 50 years it's been
really exponentiating a lot I'm gonna go
out on a limb here you were asking about
the signal-to-noise what if the noise is
being interpreted as the signal my
argument would be that you don't know
what the signal is and the reason is
because the entire United States and
really the whole world has actually lost
sight of what the purpose is there are
two different phenomena one's called
pleasure one's called happiness they are
not the same there are seven differences
between pleasure and happiness pleasure
short-lived happiness is long lived
pleasure is visceral you feel that in
your body happiness is ethereal you feel
it above the neck pleasure is taking
happiness is giving pleasures
experienced alone happiness is usually
experienced in social groups pleasure is
achievable with substances happiness is
not achievable with substances the
extremes of pleasure whether it be
substances or behaviors all lead to
addiction there's an a holic after every
one of them whether it's you know
sexaholic alcoholic chocoholic
Shopaholic but there's no such thing as
being addicted to too much happiness
and finally pleasures dopamine happiness
is serotonin
not the same my argument is that we've
lost sight of the difference because
we've been told for the last 50 years
that pleasure is happiness
the noise became the signal yeah so I
think what you're saying yeah we use the
terms eudaimonia sometimes and and
eudaimonia is what aristotle referred to
as contentment right feeling of this
feels good I don't want or need anymore
compared to say reward which is this
feels good I want more right they are
not the same so yeah so then there's a
there's a satisfaction in with a life
well-lived is a really different
experience than the momentary of
experience of pleasure and it's really
important to think about that in terms
of how these systems are designed and
what their are supporting so my thought
about signal-to-noise is really to think
about what is the signal what is the
signal that we want these systems to be
carrying I actually think right now
Westin great thanks so I actually think
it's possible right now to construct a
system this is something I put time into
at various times how can I build my
digital environment so that the signal
it carries is one that's positive so I
have at various time spent time really
tailoring like my Facebook newsfeed to
really carry the things I care about and
if filter out the things things that I
think support my my what did you call it
happiness versus pleasure right yeah but
my long-term bulbs because you want
right right not necessarily the things
that make me feel great right but the
things that when I step back I think
this is gonna help me be a better person
so I want content that really helps me
you know think about like learn about
how to work out better right get nudges
to go running in the morning right I can
set up my phone right now if I'm very
careful I can set up my phone to do that
but by default if I don't if I just take
it as it comes a night
all the apps and use all the default
settings that is not what I get so I
think that is a real one of the real
challenges that is really important and
necessary if we're not if these if these
devices are going to be something that's
compatible with happiness and the left
well lived
I think stewardship is a good one I
think learning to feel feeling feeling
yourself feeling your heart feeling
other people feeling a broader range of
emotion these are the things that I
would call signal and if you could
somehow deliver stewardship of Earth and
stewardship of civilization to other
people a signal through technology I
think that's a great use of technology
great yeah I love it and I actually just
had one more thought so thank thank you
for giving me a second so when I started
graduate school one of the first issues
we were presented with there's actually
a crisis in in the mental healthcare
delivery system and that crisis is that
we have as it's structured now we're
fundamentally unable to deliver enough
treatment to reach everybody in the
world who needs you know as as Robert
mentioned we have you know four percent
of the world
how many therapists do you think that
that takes to see somebody for an hour a
week all those people you know minimum
of 10 to 12 sessions you literally we
could train you know almost the whole
country and it takes you know it took
eight years to for me to finish you know
to get trained up in nursing 300 million
people right yeah so so literally you
know so the math has been done and it's
just mathematically not possible let
alone financially so how are we going to
actually address the scale of the mental
health problems that that some of the
you know that predate this is not all
due to technology where we already had
these issues and that and now they're
being exacerbated too so the same thing
that's the problem when I started grad
school was actually we were seeing it as
the answer I was really excited about
the potential especially for smartphones
to actually reach people at scale and
actually provide a potentially an answer
to this problem and it's been so it's
been amazing as to see how quickly that
vision has
of the dark side of it has has taken
over and just in the last few years but
you know the in terms of the signal you
know for us in mental health these
devices are actually one of our also of
the simultaneously one of our only the
one of the only hopes we have for
actually addressing this problem at
scale so we really need them to carry
this signal
Tristan Harris did a quick search of
happiest apps and the most unhappy apps
I'm just gonna read you the list of both
real quick and keep them like close most
happy apps ready calm Google Calendar
head space inside timer the weather
MyFitnessPal audible ways Amazon music
podcasts Kindle Evernote Spotify weather
canvas yeah so what do all of those have
in common no tuning in word right there
one-way apps the app goes from the app
to you now let's look at the most
unhappiest interesting the app to you
yeah yeah to you yeah now the most
unhappy apps ready Grindr candy crush
saga Facebook WeChat candy crush read at
Tweetbot Weibo tinder subway surf two
dots Instagram snapchat 10/10 and clash
Royale what are those have in common
there are two apps the problem is who
you're two weighing with random people
random people mostly anonymous so my
question is can you connect with
anonymous you know Zuckerberg says we
connect people
that's not connection its connectivity
but it's not connection connection is
eye-to-eye face-to-face connection and
there's a reason that it's got to be
eye-to-eye face-to-face you have a set
of neurons in the back of your head and
your occipital lobe called mirror
neurons you record from them and what
they're doing is they're reading the
facial expressions of the person you're
talking to in real time
and they are basically transducing that
facial expression into emotion that you
then adopt and we have a name for this
process it's called
empathy and if you can't do it you are a
psychopath
think about it so some of the technology
that we are building is causing a
decrease in empathy therefore an
increase in psychopathy absolutely and
that cell phone in your pocket forty
percent less empathy because it's in
your pocket so Robert let me ask you a
question how good would technology have
to get before we were able to achieve
that level of connection with somebody
who's not physically present with us
hell if I know
like the matrix kind of levels yeah I
don't know let me let me move
conversation on to before we get to Q&A
there's a really pressing points that I
want to talk about I want to talk about
the end of privacy because it looks like
we're leaving
privacy completely behind we're using we
want the Google Maps data therefore we
contribute to the Google Maps data we
want the benefits of these products
therefore we contribute with our data
these products so if if it's if if we're
going to be in a place where we are
completely decentralizing our data and
all data is decentralized and it can be
anonymous and it can be helpful this is
some magical land of possibility that
I'm envisioning hopefully hopefully then
there's another darker siloed data being
manipulated all this different type of
stuff what are your thoughts on and also
along with the end of privacy
where does geopolitics it with the end
of privacy there is a massive arms race
for data going on so where if you stop
collecting data because you're like I
want to do this differently and then
China or Russia or wherever else in the
world continues to collect as much data
as possible and make
their algorithms better make their a is
better where do we go what are your
thoughts on privacy and geopolitics easy
just whip up an answer right on the spot
so this really comes back to the
attention economy I mean it really is
how much I mean it sounds to me like
you're kind of taking a geopolitical
event to this I personally believe that
at this point the bigger geopolitical
factor that's also a little more
relevant to what we're talking about now
is just capitalism kind of having a
stranglehold on the political processes
around the world even see this in China
I mean China's a de jure communist
nation that is de facto completely
capitalist at this point I mean they
have stock market crashes and everything
like it's totally would have been
unimaginable 40 years ago but um so as a
result this is really a question of if
the attention economy is really you know
behind all these issues or if it's
actually something deeper and more
fundamental with human psychology and
its inability to handle these new
technologies that we have I think if
it's the first thing the the attention
economy really kind of causing all these
problems in of itself that's probably
easier to address then the latter
scenario where it really is just
something about our minds are not
equipped to handle the accessibility of
information that has been given to us
through computers and and smartphones I
can throw in a one little quick plug
here for capitalism though I think
capitalism will give us what we want not
necessarily what we say we want right
but what a lot of people seem too deep
down inside for whatever reason that we
may or may not approve of seem to want
so I feel that it's like you were saying
before I'd like it's our responsibility
and it's a responsibility a lot of
people who care about this subject to to
teach people that what they think they
might want in the short term might not
be very healthy for them in the long
term you know similarly to what what has
been done with a lot of other you know
horrible and and and and distasteful
addictive substances and the
is to to understand how to use them in
moderation where you can and to abstain
from them where you where you can't seem
to juice them in moderation but it's up
to us to to do that to teach that and
then to change the underlying demand in
the population at large from what it
currently is to something that we
perhaps feel is better in the long run
do you think that the things that people
desire are inherently kind of virtuous
or do you think they inherently desire
procrastination and you know pedaling
through life with a bunch of kind of
boredom satisfying programs I think we
have both I think as humans we are we're
always torn between these two poles and
we should do our best to help people to
feel like they're able to satisfy a
little bit of those dopamine hits a
little bit of those more primal
instincts while doing something that is
in the long run potentially what they
themselves would say that they would
want to do in the long run if only they
have the right tools the right services
the right companies the right technology
is providing it for them and I'm going
to tell you you're full of crap both of
you and the reason is because education
alone has not solved any substance of
abuse or behavior of abuse and it's not
going to that's why it's abused that's
why it's addictive because you can know
that whatever substance you're addicted
to is ruining your health your family
your economy or society your community
and you are powerless to do anything
about it
and that's what the data show shows that
every single substance and every single
behavior has required some form of
societal intervention whether it be
alcohol the gin act of 1736 whether it
be tobacco whether the methamphetamine
whether it be cocaine whether it be
heroin whether it be gambling
it doesn't matter rehab and laws rehab
personal
intervention laws societal intervention
rehab and laws rehabbing laws what is
your end there are no laws for
technology can Robert give a solution
please on what you think would be a good
solution to the like Internet addiction
one here on a societal level it's not
education well so how to you know the
genies out of the bottle it's not like
we're going back and I'm not sure we
should go back I mean technology
ultimately is a tool it could be for
good or for bad the question is how do
you make it quote humane and you know
the Center for Humane Technology I'm an
advisor to are trying to engage
developers in figuring out how to do
those things I think ultimately there
probably will be ways and I'm not a
techie so you know I'm a technological
Luddite I really you know that's not my
thing like my issue is the the
neuroscience I think that ultimately
will be ways there are things that will
you know maybe it'll be limitation of
access maybe there'll be specific you
know dampers on reward or profit maybe
the business model will change so that
it will actually pay business developers
to promote something that works for the
good rather than for the bad as an
example you know I'm the anti sugar guy
you know why don't we subsidize real
food and tax processed food and use the
money from the tax to fund the subsidy
then it would all of a sudden be in big
foods best interest to do the right
thing instead of the wrong thing
ultimately I think we can provide
incentives to make developers want to do
the right thing but we can't do it using
the current business model which is
eyeballs okay as long as it's about
eyeballs
you can't win maybe it'll be a
subscription model you know maybe people
will you know like like cigarettes you
know you got to pay a lot you know and
make it hurt
you know maybe that'll be the way the
be you know some method for doing it but
the current method clearly does not work
whatever I have to I have to I have to
respond to this a little bit though I
have to expel some of the crap that was
coming up so I I don't mean to say that
teaching is the right solution here
right so if somebody were to have come
to me when I was playing World of
Warcraft in college and said look by the
way it's just probably not gonna be that
helpful for you 10 years down the line
it's feels really good today but really
although side note I got my first job by
telling somebody I ran a World of
Warcraft guild so you know there's that
but I think that the Ulta got off of it
and the other people who I saw who were
addicted to the game frankly stopped
playing it was not because anybody told
them to it wasn't because blizzard
raised a subscription price of World of
Warcraft by fivefold right it wasn't
because a regulator came in and said
Blizzard Entertainment that's the
company that makes world of warcraft we
need you guys to stop using variable
rewards that's just not gonna work here
that wasn't it at all
it was just that in their lives they
found other things including myself that
I felt were more meaningful than mice
than the time I was spending in World of
Warcraft and I think for a lot of people
their lives are they don't have access
to that ability to get meaning and and
purpose from something else in their
lives and I feel like in terms of
innovators in terms of technologists
that's one of the ways in which we could
really work to address the problem is
giving people alternatives that we feel
fulfill them gives them that meaning and
purpose in their life and doesn't do it
in a way that is ultimately
self-destructive so that's at least
personally that's my approach right with
civility I feel like this is the
ultimate in giving people that ability
to engage intellectually which is deep
and fulfilling face-to-face because I'm
not getting that fulfillment from I
personally wasn't getting that
fulfillment from all the other ways in
life that I that social interactions
through Facebook etc and I hope that
other people feel the same way and it's
through having these alternatives that
people will migrate off or at least many
people will migrate off of these less
healthy forms of engagement and man we
just come back good good great points
there may we come back to end of privacy
and geopolitics thoughts on
that on the police there's so many
directions to go in and it's make me
appreciate that yes together because it
is such a multi-faceted complicated
question that we're trying to answer
like how do we make this all work with
our systems and our personalities I I'm
hopeful that social networks 2.0
includes more human connection I'm
hopeful that bringing Mike I'm hopeful
that nation-states start to collaborate
in the face of potential
self-determination I mean look like on
the way here the ways that the worst air
quality on earth right now is right
outside our door
yeah the wake-up calls getting louder
and I'm really inspired to see lots of
people starting to think a lot more
radically about different ways of being
with with each other with technology
with the environment with themselves and
yeah in this day and age I don't think
it's enough for companies just to be
mission driven I think we really need to
be questioning every aspect of what
we're doing in order to create the
beautiful world that we actually want to
live in and so yeah I'm hopeful that
this this awareness grows globally that
Millennials coming into power can signal
to each other that this is something we
value as a people this is something that
we care about we want to fund learning
outcomes to understand and make that
transparent so we're all on the same
team here on earth trying to make it
work together it's really forcing us to
evolve as a species and so I may say
about like where we are is really an
epicenter of that of experimentation and
debate and solidarity so you know I my
area is not geopolitics and privacy laws
but when I look at the at that level and
the systems of what are happening the
thing that there's an addiction I think
that we go is totally untreated in a
capitalist system and or to really those
are addictions to wealth and power and I
call them addictions because they are
unhealthy megalomania so we know that
you know life satisfaction has no
relationship to income above a basic
level of you know meeting your need
right that's the number you often hear
right and and so beyond that what are
you actually doing what are you trying
to accomplish you're not actually making
your life better but your brain you know
just like we get pulled into games like
we get pulled into substances like we
get pulled into Facebook your brain is
telling you yet you know make that extra
that next million and you're gonna feel
better things are gonna be better and
guess what it's not I guess what we
guess what people do then
well the 1 million didn't help maybe 2
million maybe 10 maybe a billion what if
you give that money to people like
artists and entrepreneurs around the
world and right yeah and it turns out
there you see a few people realizing
this you know you see Warren Buffett
realizing this and you know Bill Gates
right some of these people are realizing
it at least to some extent right they
they obviously got you know got to where
they got by being pulled into this right
but I think that we if this if this was
something you know if I had a megaphone
and I could kind of broadcast something
across the world it would be that we
really need to take this seriously and
start really talking about the fact that
we're not building a society that works
for anybody if we just allow these
forces to we and we kind of idealize
them and allow them to go unchecked and
that's kind of my hope for the world is
that people because otherwise these
people are going to continue to just try
to grab every dollar they can and try to
get control of everything they can but
the way that we can unhook this is to
understand that actually you know it's
society that's better for everyone if we
build it in a different way
yeah that's great that's great
[Applause]
that's that's pretty damn good in terms
of the conversation I feel I feel pretty
good ending there I feel like we know
that would there needs to be some sort
of change and I think we're we're
beautifully growing through that that
change right now although Robert at
times is like yeah I feel you may may we
let's give our panel around of applause
please
all right we got some time for Q&A we'd
love to open up for
[Music]